[Applause]
hey comedy huh we're really doing it
folks thanks for coming up good to be
here hey how you doing nice to see a
good shirt how are you
cleavage that's exciting hey don't get
weird you brought it all right here we
are sorry I gotta work on saying things
to people out loud yeah I got a problem
I just say what I see I think I'm
autistic but just like the bad parts of
it you know like I can't compute numbers
or remember dates but I'll make you feel
weird all right let you drop bunch of
toothpicks I can't count them but I'll
give you a shitty hug I'm working on it
trying to get better flew here from New
York man I hate flying you know they let
you pick your seat on a plane I think
I'd rather pick the person I'm sitting
next to I don't really give a [ __ ] where
I am on the plane it's like a five-hour
relationship make it more like a dating
app obese Nazi with a service dog swipe
left tiny asian lady with a surgical
mask that's my girl
yes she is not a talker Hey
but just like a dating app she shows up
with a baby I'm like I got catfished
hate the small talk to things I can't do
small talk and eye contact how's that is
that you know I basically of all the
traits of a serial killer just without
the ambition I'm working on it people I
say mark gotta be more confident they
say mark gotta be yourself I'm like well
you got a pick one I can't do both of
those like a lot of people are scared of
skydiving I'm more scared of the banter
on the plane that I am jumping out of it
yeah you sit in the plane it's all windy
you're strapped in some guys like so
mark where you're from just like say
we're supposed to go together I got it
at least with skydiving you get an
instructor what about stuff I'm bad at
stuff I'm nervous about like a dinner
party I make dinner parties have screwed
up set me up with a pro right I just
show up some guys like all right I'll
take care of my god beautiful he's
giving me tips don't say the N word got
it she's not pregnant don't ask thank
god you're here okay some guys the
party's like so who's your favorite
comic I'm like Bill Cosby he's like pull
the shoot
I'm working on it I had a chatty uber
driver last week that's the worst this
guy wouldn't shut up I forgot that the
no small talk option on the app so I get
creative I just scare the guy and being
quiet he's like how about this traffic
huh
what are things causing this I'm like
probably the Jews he's like like all
right I give this ride five stars of
David yeah I'm working on it you know
always trying to get better I'm a weirdo
that's why I drink big fan of the booze
I gotta cut back I actually gotta let go
from a job once for being drunk at work
my boss called me and egos get in here
mark it's clear you're a
high-functioning alcoholic I was like
wow how do you know I was also high this
guy is good one of my friends is like a
beer expert you know he's like we gotta
go to a brewery I'm like why can't we go
to a bar he think it's funny you see how
it's made I don't care how it's me look
I like porn I don't need to go to a
broken home
not saying all porn sir I'm broken home
just the ones I like seems like a lot of
people are quitting the booze now it's
kind of going away all my friends are
getting sober look that's good but some
people are better when they're drinking
there's a lot of bad Sobers out there
yeah we always start with the negative
part about booze what about the good
like sure you drove through a playground
but you could dance man trying to get
better I'm in therapy anybody else hey
there you go a couple people yeah yeah
I'm doing this thing called exposure
therapy that's where you face your fears
Garrett hikes take four hot air balloons
scared of drowning takes you in the
ocean so he said what are you scared of
Marcus oh I'm claustrophobic and scared
of intimacy so he took me a little
closet and [ __ ]
very expensive
yeah why the stigma with therapy why all
my friends make fun of me I think should
be mandatory but he works out their
muscles why not work out your emotions
I'll be hanging out with a friend he's a
guy right man take it easy I'm gonna go
work on arms and back I'm like cool I'm
gonna go work on letting go of the past
and accepting love everybody loves the
gym who the gym makes me feel sexy well
you know what else is sexy not being a
walking red flag
nobody cares me your abs you think the
guy having a meltdown at Chili's
I think people respect the gym coz
there's a culture behind al like gym
rats they have t-shirts that say
beastmode and better sore than sorry
therapy people we need t-shirts we a
shirt says no dad no problem right
like can't stop won't stop crying I
could have used some therapy as a kid
weird kid bed wetter oh yeah I wet the
bed every day Louis 13 years old my
mattress looked like a goddamn coffee
filter I ruined a lot of sleepovers
folks yeah you start to run out of
excuses after a while now your friends
like what happened here I was like haha
jeez I must dispelled a cup of piss
yeah they say a lot of bed-wetters
become serial killers which I believe
because we learn how to clean up a stain
pretty quick that's how embarrassing it
is wetting the bed almost about to be
known as a murderer than a bed wetter
you know your friend sits on your
mattress why is it all crinkly I'm gonna
kill ya
but a grown-up now 36 years old I grew
up before the Internet maybe a better
time for a kid maybe a question back
then hey mom what's the capital of South
Dakota
she's like I'm on the phone and you just
didn't know what a concept not knowing
now we have so much information right
there now I have an Alexa I love this
thing and Alexa is like a mom without
the passive aggressiveness asking you
want hey Alexa how many cups in a liter
four point two three cups all right if
I'm like hey mom how many cups in a
liter she's like won't you check your
mattress sing that Alexa's tricky I read
an article recently that said Alexa
actually listens everything you say
stores in the database could use it
against you later it's like damn just
like a real woman
now I'm all nervous like I Alexa what's
the weather out there she's like why
don't you ask Siri oh boy here we go
yeah it's got to be hard to be a kid now
I feel bad for kids so much stimulus
coming to kids iPhone internet social
media remember I happy-go-lucky where's
kids not a care in the world maybe run
in the car
shotgun that was like the biggest
problem my life shotgun yeah I never see
kids doing that anymore the only time a
kid yells it out now is in a classroom
school shootings what a bummer huh
the great American pastime yeah school
shootings like the menstruation of
America happens about once a month it's
bloody and every kid goes well I guess
it's my turn now I know they're bad I
like other blame in the video games
video games cause violence come on video
games don't cause violence video games
cause carpal tunnel and vaginal dryness
I know a lot of guys they play eight
hours of video games a day the
girlfriends are like violent slap my ass
choke me I'm dying here like I don't
think games translate to real life I
grew up playing Monopoly with my friends
none of them now owned property
to be fair some did go directly to jail
that's uh we got it they got problems
here you know like I just got back from
Europe they really make fun of us over
there that's like all they do oh you
Americans just so fat like a yeah we're
doing great why is it a bad thing how
fat we are I think it's cool it's like
impressive more people die in America of
obesity and starvation which is like hey
we did it how cool are we we're dying
from eating food we go up to heaven some
guys like I starve to death what
happened to you we're like snacks
yeah the McRib is back what do you want
seek well how'd you lose your foot
frostbite nah frosting yeah we're fat
I'm so high up on the food chain one of
my friends he only eats grass fed beef
you realize how crazy is that means he
gets to pick what he eats eats that's
pretty good and here's the weird thing
cows eat grass that's what we've messed
with our food when something eats wood
it's supposed to we brag about it
that's like saying hey no my 4 year old
is sober
[Music]
father of the year over here
yeah we're fat all my friends are fat
mostly my family's fat I grew up pretty
fat you know I I tried to make fun of
fat people unless they make fun of me
that's when I let it go yeah like all my
fat friends give me [ __ ] one of my frat
friends told me I have skinny privilege
like privilege something can't be a
privilege if you could do it too I've
known you my whole life he used to be
thin that's not a privileges can't be
attained by exercising right if that
were the case then black people take a
Jazzercise class they wouldn't get
pulled over right it'd be that simple
he always condescends to me oh you're so
lucky you're thin lucky you gotta work
at it it's hard what the hell I gotta
eat right it sucks
saying you're so lucky your thins like
saying you're so lucky you don't have
kids no no I had food and I pulled out
he's like whatever it's easy being
skinny well not really you couldn't do
it yeah I read a news article about
obesity they said they're thinking about
putting microchips in obese people's
brains it shocks them every time I think
about food I was like if we have that
kind of technology I feel like we should
be using that on pedophiles why are we
wasting on chubs I don't care about your
candy intake I'm worried about your
candy output priorities people eat all
the cupcakes you want just don't touch a
Little Debbie pedophilia huh any
pedophiles here
I mean statistically he's gotta be to
write but hey we're all adults here
which is a sentence they hate you guys
have read down your knees and thank God
not a pedophile they didn't choose that
they got dealt a bad hand we're
extremely lucky we should be grateful
think about clothes we all were when I
was in third grade I was attracted to
third grade girls now I like adult women
when I was in third grade I like grape
juice now I like red wine but I still
like grape juice
holy hell that was close thank God my
brain just knew the right way to go whoo
I just watched a documentary on Petofi
with my friend my friend goes ooh I
could never have sex with a kid they're
so annoying I was like that's it huh
that's the thing that's holding you back
need a better reason that all right
buddy it's like hey what happened to
Greg he went to prison why he met a
really cool kid that checks out all
right yeah but it's good to get out of
New York that's it he'll eat you alive
you know good to be here I live in the
West Village in Manhattan you know a
real cool neighborhood the gay pride
parade actually goes rap on my house
every day and I like a gay area you guys
are the best progressive non violent you
never made any violent gay guys there's
no gay gangs that would just be a
musical any gay guys here tonight hey
all right
thanks for coming out
big fan one of my best friends is gay
he's obsessed with straight guys it's
like his thing you know he's like I love
flipping ahead a row he's like you know
how hard that is now hardest go out
every night to bunch of people you want
to have sex with her don't to have sex
with you I was like that's exactly it's
like we in a straight guy the hell are
you talking about I would argue it's
just hard me to sleep with a woman is
for you to flip a hetero he was like nah
Donna you have no idea you got to take
him out for hours convince them yeah
yeah same here
he's like nine I even if you do pull it
off which is like a miracle they feel
horrible after yeah yeah same thing we
went back and forth for hours talking
about this all night back and forth
eventually I woke up at his place oh
[Applause]
yeah I went to the gay pride parade last
year still sore had a good time at a lot
of characters out there I made a gay guy
there hated straight people I never
heard that he's a hetero phob I didn't
know that was a thing
he was like yeah screw straight people
you guys are the worst oh come on man we
gotta get along also without us you
wouldn't be here don't bite the hand
that breeds you
yeah and I have to ask who's gay sir cuz
I have the worst gaydar on the bike
can't tell who's gay one of my friends
always bragged about his gaydar well god
he's like he's gay he's gay he's gay I'm
like well that's not that impressive I
mean right a gay bar I don't know you
want impressed with your gaydar start
pointing out gay babies now that's
impressive right like see that kid
breastfeeding over there between you and
me he's miserable that's a hell of a gay
me yeah I like all the girl esby ins any
lesbians in the house hey Wow yes I love
your web sites feel like lesbians are
underrepresented I travel the country
doing comedy I always see fun gay bars
in every city they always have fun names
like the manhole or the back door
where's all the fun lesbian bars where's
like the dugout or scissors also you
always see a group of girls with one gay
guy on a never see a group of guys with
one lesbian I'd love to have a lesbian
in my crew that'd be fun cuz hey guys
very helpful to help girls with the hair
or their outfit look I'm a lesbian help
me out with stuff like I crapped the car
won't start she's like I got it
yeah you flooded it you [ __ ] thanks
Debbie glad you brought your tools
it's that tire alright but you guys are
cool you know a lot of crowds getting
sensitive
it's getting weird out there I got
yellow show recently this guy goes hey
buddy that's a trigger word I was like
whoa I think it's pronounced trigger
easy there big fella
hey look you know if you get upset or
offended that's cool I'm not one of
those guys you're allowed to be offended
that's totally cool but if you are just
shut up you're not a hero just ruining a
show just be offended just let it flow
through you just feel it right and I'll
share we don't care just feel yeah we
all have thoughts I might want to sleep
with your girlfriend I just hold it in I
don't say we're so obsessed with words
now kind of shows how good we have we
got to focus on words you know like in
the 70s it was all about actions like if
you want to show you were brave and the
seventies you to jump over 12 buses on a
motorcycle now I see a guy make an
off-color joke at the office I'm like
that guy's [ __ ] fearless Wow yeah I
don't know people take things so
seriously I guess I got to show you
their personality by yelling at you
about stuff that bothers them I don't
know like I don't meet any of this stuff
I'm just saying words in a certain order
to elicit laughter people like trying to
figure me out do my act it's all jokes
I told an abortion joke recently and a
woman approached me she was like hey
that's very insensitive I've had an
abortion you shouldn't tell jokes like
that I was like whoa hey sorry I just
old a joke I think what you did was much
worse
but you know either way I'll see it home
later honey
and again all jokes I love abortions I
paid for two last week I'm a fan right
hey you remember yeah it's all jokes
friend of mine she works at Planned
Parenthood she loves that joke I was
like I might have to get rid of it
people don't like it she's like no no
you got to keep it I was like I might
get rid of psych no no you got to keep
it I was like I was like don't tell me
do with my body of work she's like every
jokes a miracle but I don't want to
upset anybody you know ah jeez I don't
want to upset that's not my intent you
know I'm upsetting people on accident
now I was at a Starbucks recents guy
hanging my coffee on hey thanks chief
this guy goes ooh
don't say chief it's offensive to Native
Americans I was like how is that
offensive he goes whoa don't say how gah
how do we get here weird times weird
times taking words away you know I get
it you know words hurt people I get it
you know but here's the thing we're kind
of like a weird word prohibition can't
say this can't say that that's why I
feel like every now and then we should
all go to a plea in correct speakeasy
this is where we can all go to say
horrible stuff and nobody cares
you got no hate in your heart you don't
wanna hurt anybody but if you can't say
it there give us a place you can write
you go down some creaky stairs you're
bang on a big steel door or the guys
like what's the password [ __ ]
it's like the 90s again yeah cuz
offensive words they're like alcohol
sure you can abuse it sure you can hurt
people if you do responsibly it's a good
time just don't do it at work don't you
around kids will go home close the door
take the edge off a [ __ ]
right I don't say little people that's
like drinking no duels but of course I
get it I just you know find it funny I
get it but here's the problem we forget
that no one's politically correct up
here we're all animals and we're all
trying to we're all seeing the same
thing we're all thinking the same thing
no one's PC in their brain this is a
filter you Pro when he talks you seem
nice
like no one sees a hot girl bend over
and thinks look at that independent
woman like to treat her equally now
we're sick man and women we're gross but
like where it's all gotten us done if
you like the whole country's pent up
feel surprised angry right now we got
white supremacist protest hate groups
it's weird you're allowed to be hateful
in America as long as you're not
specific and that weird if you're like I
hate Mexican people everybody's like oh
my god what a bigoted prejudice but if
you're like I hate people it was like oh
[ __ ] right and that worse people are
angry now man I have one of those white
lives matter rally as a couple my house
the other day I freaked out then I
realized uh it's just a half marathon
that was close I don't know just be a
good person what about that just be nice
to people you know yeah like a lot of it
doesn't add up I can't keep track of all
the rules like transgender what do you
think that's how I feel I don't give a
[ __ ] you want to go for a man a woman go
nuts well go labia what's the beef look
it's weird to hate someone cuz they're
trans right but it's also weird to love
someone cuz they're trans shouldn't you
like them based on who they are as a
person content to the character people
are so phony
I love Caitlyn Jenner why she sucks
she's against gay marriage I ran over a
person what's the good part I think oh
wow they have hard lives all right well
sort of digits
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag I don't
see any tweets about midgets who's got a
heart in a minute hug it around hard to
drive hard to get work no love it look
I'm not inside trans but I am pro midge
I just don't get why we help one group
but not another it's just kind of trendy
and people say well trans aren't allowed
everywhere well you're been a roller
coaster
[Music]
least trans be accommodated with the
bathrooms midgets you ever seen out
tallit oil tis well imagine I'm gonna
jump to take a dump weird no help no
support you know what's great about
midgets I got a couple [ __ ] friends
they're good eggs you never see a [ __ ]
complaining never every other group
complains never a [ __ ] never see it on
the news sitting at a desk legs dangle
old fishing never every other group
complains I see women on new is we have
a glass ceiling midgets like you're
worried about the ceiling holy [ __ ] I'm
trying to [ __ ] with this counter baby
interesting see I guess I'm too
open-minded because I support all
transition not just sexual why do we
stop at sexual I support transition a
personality transition of a opinion
right like Kevin Hart Kevin Hart got in
trouble with some offensive tweets from
years ago well I'm not the same guy was
from years ago I've transitioned I used
to have sex with sixteen year olds when
I was 16 now I don't I'm different well
years ago he said some offensive stuff
well years ago she won the men's relay
people change okay why do you support
that and not that ah it just tells me if
I ever get in trouble now I'm just gonna
get a sex change cuz you gotta kiss my
ass hey Mark we heard that interview
from ten years ago
yeah that was Mark I'm Margaret I don't
know I support Kevin Hart also exudes a
[ __ ] I don't everything's weird now
you know the news is insane the
Internet's full of hate I feel like it's
a little things to keep you happy now I
got to cherish the little things
I got a Snapple today I love a good
Snapple I love that fun fact under the
cap I was a good one today it said uh
polar bears used to be brown but through
evolution they turned white biggest
police were shooting them I know I
couldn't believe they fit all that under
the cap
yeah ah yes a lot of racial talk now
white privilege its term here a lot now
white privilege but I thought it was all
about diversity so should we talk about
everybody religious why were just
limiting it to whitey let's spread the
love let's make every group feel good
everybody's got something to all people
privilege see the concert Jews no hell
pretty good pretty good women ladies
night that's cool black people I can't
wear a purple suit looks like fun
everybody's got a perk Indian people
even if you're undateable your parents
will arrange something huh let's spread
the love
who's got the energy to be racist huh
that's gotta suck to be racist would
that be weird just like you go to the
bank like oh there's Jews e'er I gotta
leave what a horrible life man put on an
outfit go to a meeting all that stuff
I don't care about any group enough to
hate it do it whatever everyone go nuts
I know I don't to do anything I'm lazy I
want to burn a cross or a calorie yeah
everybody's worked up about something
these there's Muslims on airplanes I'd
rather a Muslim on a plane than a baby
never had a Muslim kick the back of my
seat and piss in the aisle I'm just
saying the airport had a baby band I
wouldn't protest
yeah but transgender they're using the
bathrooms well they're still using the
toilet right they're not leaving a hot
floater in the sink
if that was like their thing then yeah
we should totally have a meeting that's
crazy
no and you get the hillbilly guy well
one of these perverts puts on a dress
and looks my wife in the bathroom oh
what a score some guy your toothless
wife [ __ ] come on go to work you
lunatic
but hey we've come a long way we hate to
admit that we hate to admit it we've
come a long way like in the 50s we had
whites only and blacks only water
fountain which is incredibly sad
especially if you're a thirsty Asian
what the hell were they doing drinking
out of a faucet no one talks about I
never come up once not a peep nothing
black Bueller pissed can you believe
this [ __ ] we got our own water fountain
aged like could I get a sip I'm dying
out here
I got a triangular hat to block the Sun
I'm a big fan of Asians I think they're
the best group I think they're number
one I don't think they get the credit
they deserved I'm an Asian supremacist
all the way I think they're better than
the rest of any Asian people here hey
all right you should be working God what
are you doing having a good time that's
not the Asian I know god damn it I want
you to dealing blackjack or sitting on a
box peeling something come on big fan
best group easily the best group no love
you guys get the short on the chopstick
it's pretty unfair so quiet so secure
Asians every other groups got a brag and
boast every groups got a slogan black
people I'm black and I'm proud white
people white power Hispanics oh yeah not
an Asian in just head down grades up
that's it ain't you the bet you never
hear about Asian crime never if I was an
Asian guy would you start bugging people
like hey it's my word against yours big
fan big fan oh yeah I think the news is
a problem the news pins us all against
each other news makes it seem like all
white people are scared of minorities I
don't think all white pillars scared of
minorities I do think a lot of white
people are scared of looking racist
that's really the big fear with whitey
like if I'm walking down the street of
for the morning I see a sketchy looking
white guy coming towards I'm like crap
I'm gonna cross the street if I'm
walking down the street at 4:00 in the
morning I see a sketchy looking black
guy coming towards I'm like crap I wish
I could cross the street okay I'd rather
get stabbed look like an [ __ ]
white people we are so worried about
looking ignorant and bigoted I guess
because of our history like I went
skiing Ricci with my friend we're
sitting on the ski lift I was like well
you see more black people skiing why is
that
my friend has no idea but he's gonna you
know half-ass his way through it because
you don't want to see him dumb so he's
like ah you know they don't grow up with
it like well um please II Anna I'm here
Wow
skis very expensive all right right
right yeah yeah you know I've never seen
a black guy with anything expensive on
their feet
just say you don't know it's alright you
sound way worse that's why black pillar
smarter why did we do crazy stuff we
swim with sharks we go bungee jumping
cliff diving ask a black guy why do they
do that I go I don't know that's why
people [ __ ] that's a good answer
they don't sit around you know Europe
yeah look yeah I'm a white guy if I talk
about race now for some reason another
white person Emily calls me racist
that's like what we do it's like I know
you're trying to seem like a hero buddy
gonna ruin that word you're gonna take
the teeth out of its like an important
word you're gonna ruin it like I was on
the subway where you say I was watching
an interracial couple make out I was
just staring at him
and the guy next to them copping you
guys what the hell I see you staring at
them
what are you racist I was like what
racist no I'm a creep what do you talk
about I'm hard not a racist I'm aroused
it's an important where people abuse it
all the time friend of mine she's Puerto
Rican we grew up together so hate going
to the gym the white women there I'll
give me the stink-eye cuz they're racist
I was like damn what happened she said
well first bring my food in ate it then
I played my music really loud like oh
maybe they just hate you
let's not lump together all of Puerto
Rico cuz you're being a [ __ ] hey you're
being inconsiderate and rude take a
little ownership look with it you can't
blame everything on bigotry look I grew
up in a black neighborhood I was a
bed-wetter I'd sleep with their houses
eventually stopped inviting me over I
was like I hate white people no I ruined
their [ __ ] furniture
they didn't hate white they hated yellow
sorry huh yeah I like all the groups I
just make jokes you know remember jokes
yeah I met a nice girl in that Jewish
Yap what's that Jewish app call the
Jewish one what's the Jewish that the
other one the other one
PayPal yeah going pretty well yeah a lot
of ladies here tonight that's exciting
yeah I feel like this is like your time
ladies this is like the year of the
woman you know I went to the women's
March in Manhattan that was cool
although I gotta say I haven't heard the
word [ __ ] yelled that much since that
time I rollerbladed to high school that
was a tough morning yeah it's kind of
crazy what women go through it and it
like some guy just like whip it out and
stuff in front of women that's wild
that's bold see I have a penis so I'm
not that scared of new ones but I guess
if you don't have a penis that no one's
got to be pretty scary the closer I get
to that feeling is once I was hanging
out with a friend and he just took out a
gun I was like what the hell are you
doing he's like well you know I had a
gun and I'm like yeah we're at Whole
Foods
because it dick and a gun are very
similar if somebody pull out either one
right now we'd all be like whoa is that
meant for me Jesus Christ don't point it
at me damn they're gonna gun very
similar both pointy they shoot things
that come in different sizes you can get
a pistol or a shotgun I'm circumcised so
I'm sawed-off but I guess guys you do
that just get confused cuz ladies
sometimes you like a penis so guys the
guy she like won last night why would
she like one by the copy machine women
are so complex cuz I think generally
speaking when it comes to sex I think
men are a little more constant you know
men like boobs but we like boobs across
the board boom in the bedroom great boob
on the bus also great dick in the
bedroom great dick on the bus call the
police
nobody's calling the police on a boob
you see a boob out in the while it's
like seeing a deer you're like
it's majestic look there's two now then
your other friend walks up hey look at
that a boob we're like I you spooked it
come on yeah
we're cracking down on sexual harassment
finally that's good you know get
sexually harassed more than women the
one group pets yeah nobody ever gets
consent from a dog
nobody people just pick it up kiss it on
the face rub its belly to that weird
creepy long pet where you grab the tail
at the end
or creepy as hell with dogs and we
satellite creeps they like it they're
begging me for it yeah thank God dogs
can't talk we'd all go to jail right
just some Chihuahua in a courtroom like
firstly flip me over
then he caressed all eight of my nipples
then he slapped me on the ass repeatedly
and said you're a good girl good girl
we harassed dogs all day long and
appropriate harasses they can't talks
we'll never report you that's why
they're man's best friend
also dogs forget stuff after like two
seconds you could stick your finger up a
dog's ass and be like well that was
weird frisbee
because really when you break down our
relationship with dogs dogs are
shameless shameless [ __ ] aren't they I
mean they're like gold diggers look at
the deal we've cut with a dog like
alright pooch I will house you and feed
you back to touch you whenever I want
dogs like what are you kidding that's
[ __ ] amazing I'll do you one better
when you come home I'll hump your leg
I'll lick my balls in front yeah when
you have sex
I'll watch that's fair and cats cats the
exact tops a catcher like sexual assault
victims they're all nervous get his head
on a swivel huh you touch me off I can
cut you okay you [ __ ]
hey you're not grabbing this [ __ ] all
right yeah
leave me alone I got was got a window
for an hour but hey you gotta listen to
ladies fellas you gotta listen you know
friend of mine she's like a big feminist
she's like I have a full bush cuz that's
how I was born I was like holy hell you
were born with a full bush that is a
terrifying baby cut the umbilical cord
I can't find it I like a strong woman I
want a woman a cat call me cat call us
ladies that'd be hilarious start yelling
out stuff at men that we don't hear
stuff that would scare a guy now you
walk past a group of girls at night when
I was like hey I'll tell you I love you
on the first date you're like Jesus
Christ and it's terrifying yeah get us
back any walk past girls like hey before
we have sex I'm gonna poke a hole in the
condom this is a horrible neighborhood
my god start the car oh you ladies are
fascinating so complex yeah one time me
and my girl were watching the news that
was a whole thing about a CEO or a Singh
his employees she said can you believe
this creep grabbed women's asses
whispered dirty stuff in their ear at
work cuz like yeah that's crazy then we
got home later in the bedroom she's like
can you do that stuff from the news to
me I was like I thought you hated that I
got hate he does it if you do it it's
hot oh so you hate harassment less you
like the guy then it turns you on that's
fascinating I don't think other groups
like black guys get harassed by the cops
for the night they're not like come on
pull me over
yeah tase me [ __ ] yeah interesting yeah
my gal she likes being insulted in the
bedroom which is cool but nobody tells
it and not all insults are sexy I
learned that the hard way
yeah we'd be having sex I'm like yeah yo
[ __ ] she's like yeah like yeah you [ __ ]
she's like yeah I'm like you're a bad
driver she's like what like that's the
one that bothered you
we're she's like he's really him a bad
driver like sorry a dirty skank she's
like thank you yeah yeah sometimes I'll
try to hook up and she's like I can't
have sex I don't feel sexy I can't have
sex if I don't feel sexy wow that was
the case for me I'd still be a virgin
I've never felt sexy my entire life the
whole concept of sexy is very arbitrary
you know your girl comes that I'm
wearing my sexy leopard print underwear
well when did we decide leper was the
sexiest animal print I don't know
nothing says sexy underwear to me like
yellow and brown spots in that case I'm
wearing my sexy underwear it's a rare
jungle cat called the skidmark
yeah how about the true crime you gals
love a good true crime oh that's the
Forensic Files killer women Dateline
hours of this stuff my girl called me
watching two seconds of gay porn she
flipped out she was like what the hell
is going on here I was like well you
watch murder isn't that way weirder
she's like why you're watching this do
you want to do that I was like well do
you want to kill me she was like oh shut
up I'm just watching my show so I know
what to do if I ever get in that
situation I'm like oh maybe that's why
I'm watching gay porn I wonder how this
goes down so I get the hell out of there
right she's like that's ridiculous this
is a reenactment well this is two of
this guy's not really a real estate
broker too much porn I think porn has
really changed the game you know out of
the gate now sex is much kinkier I think
is a porn out of the gate now it's like
choking spitting finger up the butt
which is weird cuz these are all things
my older brother did to torment me
it's all the same [ __ ] we've just taken
bullying out of the playground brought
in the bedroom I got my girl on top now
I'm like Indian sunburn seriously you go
to a schoolyard during recess some kids
hold a girl down pulling her hair
calling her name's I'm like man he's
good
I'm taking notes get back to your girl
she's like wow where'd you learn that
I'm like a couple of third graders
actually but don't worry I like red wine
it's weird out there who knows you gotta
get married right that's what you do Oh
scary huh
marriage feel so antiquated cousin we've
come so far with everything we're still
doing that thing what are we doing
especially the ladies
every girl if every day is like when you
gonna propose clocks tick and pop the
question why you want you're married so
bad what is it
ladies you come so far but when it comes
to marriage you guys get kind of
old-fashioned I want the ring and the
cake and the dress what grow up ladies
you're killing it go frolic be free but
it's my special day all right what if to
ruin mine I don't I feel like a lot of
guys look at marriage the way women look
at anal you know just like well we all
knew this day was coming
let's get it over with I'm not sure it's
even natural okay either way when it's
all done we'll get new sheets
[Laughter]
but that's why you ladies are brilliant
you gals are geniuses because you guys
tend to be the ones who want to get
married to Smythe designed it or the man
asks you that's some Jedi level trickery
right there
you're like Yoda I want to get married
you'll ask me yes you got it and you'll
get down on one knee no problem and
you'll buy me expensive ring will do and
whose idea was this all mine
well played ladies well played see like
guys we got a cool with the sexual
aggression we come on too strong we're
creepy were scary ladies you guys got a
cool with the commitment aggression
that's where you guys push that's what
you guys get creepy when in exchange key
what I'm gonna move in when you get
married it's like well hey no means no
slow down I feel pressured I'm not ready
huh and your family jumps in hey when do
you make an honest woman out of my
daughter
what who's this guy imagine my dad to
that hey what I'm gonna bang my son huh
back off I don't know my nuts Mayer just
feels like the least romantic thing on
the planet it's legal I gotta go to a
courthouse get a license what's the
license for that's the only license we
don't check by the way driver's license
liquor license people check a fishing
license I'm gonna start checking
marriage license next time I see a short
broke weird guy's like that's my hot
wife over there I'll be like let me see
some ID but I just got my license
renewed you know it's weird when you buy
alcohol you show your driver's license
and that weird the thing I'm not
supposed to do with this stuff you wanna
prove I can do by that logic when you
buy a gun you show your marriage license
all right lady walks in I'll take that
revolver guys like let me see some
identification why even married 60 years
you know what just take it I don't know
then you got have kids
Oh kids are scary I like babies babies
are fun you know why babies are great
because they're not evil yet as a
million douchebags out there but you
never assume that baby will become one
and that nice that's why no one ever
goes up to a pregnant woman rubs her
belly and goes ooh this one's gonna suck
no it's all up it's all potential it's
all positive oh it's kicking might be a
pro soccer player right it's never like
oh it's kicking might hit his wife
statistically way more likely in a pro
soccer player right plus it's already
hitting a woman not even out yet yeah I
don't know I got to figure something out
being a relationship is always tough you
know I've always said people say weird
stuff of me like mark you're a comedian
must be a great boyfriend why do you say
that well women love funny guys
all right we've taken the one singular
positive aspect if you deal with any guy
they could be seemed like a great
boyfriend serial killer
check out the killing this guy's
organized and cleans up after himself
terrorists check out the terrorize guys
passionate loves to travel chall
molester take out the molesting this
guy's got a van and can't wait to start
a family I just got a bad brain I'm too
literal literal is bad with dating and
stuff I had a blind date once right when
the girls saw me she goes hey I bet we'd
have really cute kids how's it go right
I bet we'd have great sex and she goes
well slow down it's like slow down
you're 9 months ahead of me ah this girl
hated me she was like you know I feel
very brave tonight I was like why is
that cuz I'm not wearing any makeup I
was like how's that brave cuz I'm being
my true self being the real me how's it
go okay she's like you should be brave
oh yeah maybe I will
she's like what he gonna do cause I'm
gonna stop hurting this is interesting
she was like wow I can't believe he just
said that I was like yeah took guts
I don't know working on it trying to get
better uh I realize I'm a weirdo I
remember I had a one-night stand once
went great fun night hanging out but
during the sex she did a new one I've
never seen before she act like a
four-year-old girl you ever come across
this we'd be having sex I don't know
where she'd be like you know if you want
to pull my hair that way keep going you
know if you want to even slap my ass you
know if you want to get choked me I was
like I do yeah we finished we had a
great night we're laying there and I was
like you know if you want to you can
leave didn't care for that when I
thought the timing was perfect you know
a lot of girls get mad about the whole
leaving thing but it's nothing personal
against you ladies just a weird um in my
head I'm a nut I'm an introvert I gotta
get out of there a lot of girls your man
like what do you just bang me and leave
oh yeah this was a long night I've been
trying to win you over like nine hours
I'm exhausted
there were five guys at the bar hitting
on you I doubt charm them be more
interesting be conversational be funny
be on all night she was like just bend
yourself like a [ __ ] stupid see
myself what I'm an idiot if I was myself
be like hey you fat or let's [ __ ]
that's not gonna work she was like well
I don't get it why do you want to leave
like I don't know I just gonna go talk
somebody but why not talk to me I just
wanted to talk to a friend we could tell
me anything well that's not true she's
like I swear to God he can tell me
anything you want yeah well I recently
had sex with a woman and she won't let
me leave so that ended what is that with
the leaving ladies don't really it's a
nerve with you guys ladies you want a
guy to stay make him want to stay like
guys we have pickup lines ladies you
need to stay put lines that's where you
kick in it's okay I approached you at a
bar I was nervous I was on my heels
shucking and jiving I made it work now
you want me to hang out so you do it
justice she's like well you're not being
that fun right now my god I already did
that that's how I [ __ ] you but now you
want me to stay so you go just a shift
change that's all win me over charm me
sweep me off my feet you do it I don't
get it girls always think I want this
kind of like me to push your boobs
together wear high heels you look sexy
as hell then a guy's sex you're like
that's it
well that's what was advertised it's
very confusing you tricked me your
outfits like a movie trailer I'm like oh
I want to see that movie I go see the
movie then I go home
I don't sit around going I gotta get to
know this theater and I'm not saying the
theater sucks or anything's wrong with
it just wasn't advertised talk to me I'd
love to I had a girl once you can't
leave you [ __ ] me
well this is this how you get people to
hang out with you how about a
conversation anecdote knock-knock
something ladies you do kegels tighten
up those stories I think it why this is
so controversial I'm just tired I'm
excited bringing the heat all night I've
been playing the hits I'm exhausted I
want to go so why could you be fake all
night I'm like we faked it too you don't
look like that you weren't makeup we're
both full of [ __ ] your eyes don't go
look at the end or whatever we're both
lying I'm just wearing makeup my
personality that's all like ladies you
know when you go to dinner with a guy or
like just cuz you bought me dinner
doesn't mean I owe you sex and that's
true but just because you let me have
sex with you doesn't mean I owe my
morning all right it's the same exact
transaction quality that's why it's
weird women go we're just as horny as
men yeah maybe we have a lot more
requirements ladies quite a checklist
you're like the Goldilocks of dick this
guy's too short this guy's too dumb this
guy's just right guys will [ __ ] the
porch
and I'm not saying one is better worse
just different week I go to the doctor
he's like what happened I was like it
was too hot but look I get it you know
it's gotta be tough to be a lady I feel
like women are getting screw in the
orgasm Department feel like men are
having way more orgasms at women and
that sucks people talk about the wage
gap the orgasm gap is out of control you
gals are getting 77 cents to the boner
like if a woman had to have an orgasm to
get pregnant there'd be like two people
here and you get nothing for you orgasm
ladies like if a guy is an orgasm going
get pregnant carry baby for nine months
deliver the baby then breastfeed the
baby and all the guy to do is this good
and he tried really hard not to do that
it's a horrible setup with a woman the
guy is all the fun the girls all the
work that'd be like if I ate a whole
chocolate cake and the girl gained
weight then she went to the gym and I
got buff gotta be tough plus women
constantly judge by your looks that's
got to be exhausting costly judged by
your look but y'all got to look good you
all look great that's how women figured
out to take the selfie up here that was
all you ladies you know you're good
sight lines are I think that's why women
like tall guys just some guy looking at
you from your best angle 100% of time
all day long that's why you don't hook
up with short guys just some guy like
jeez look at the triple chin on this
bride oh yeah
yeah you like a tall man ladies and
that's okay
it's how you're wired you're all a bunch
of height supremacist yeah that was
always the first question back on the
dating app she over six feet yeah over
six feet you over six feet
I feel bad after a while if I like to
come up with something I was like well
no but if it helps I'm still growing as
a person
well thanks I got annoyed with one girls
like how much do you weigh she was like
whoa that's body shaming it's hard for
me to lose weight it's even harder for
me to gain height plus men are so visual
that's a lot of pressure constant men
are so visual you never know your guy's
looking at my ex-girlfriend very
paranoid always going through my phone
sock drawer sniffing me always looking
for clues that's why I'm surprised you
don't see more female detectives ladies
you guys would be amazing at that you
guys are intuitive you're curious you're
persistent I feel like you gals would
crack every case as long as you thought
it was personal that's the key like man
this guy killed 18 people in Fresno so
what well he's also cheating on your
best friend give me the file crack that
case in an hour
[Music]
gotta be tough Lee's constantly judged
by your looks gotta be exhausting but
somehow men get the blame for this like
it's just men judging women which we do
but ladies you guys judge each other
quite harshly you judge yourselves by
your looks you do stuff to your looks
men even care about eat your nails done
who's that for
we don't give a [ __ ] all this jewelry
and stuff no guys are real like oh my
god see that necklace Kelly was wearing
holy hell that's all you we don't care
but it's always been friend of mine she
got breast implants so I was like hey
they look great she goes oh man so
shallow I got these for me
okay well then you're shallow
why is this on me on the sudden look
we're all shallow all right but ladies
you can tell your shell about you get
offended by friend of mine some guy call
her overweight she flipped started
dieting everyday just to spite this guy
started exercising just out of anger I
pedaled my friend got called um she
wouldn't angrily go back to college
interesting they say the C word is the
worst thing call a woman
I think it's fat what do you think
ladies C word is bad shouldn't call a
woman the C word I think fat is worse
cuz it's visible to C words an opinion
that's why no woman ever looks in the
mirror in the morning what say I just
feel Kunti today okay what do you think
Kunti is this putting off [ __ ] not doing
this I don't know you could measure fat
as a scale right there there's no unit
of measurement for the c-word that'd be
a great infomercial though wouldn't it
whoo I feel so much better after I lost
13 kuntum eaters but that's the thing
ladies I feel like you gals get so down
about your looks but you can do so many
amazing things you never really brag
about let's go through a list of stuff
women can do that's unbelievable
first of all you can make people that's
insane people are coming out of you
alive if you brag about that constantly
I know men will take a photo of a good
[ __ ]
you're making human beings how annoying
would men be if they could make people I
made him a mammy men name kiss absent
they'd even do anything
that's Jimmy jr. oh yeah would you do I
came she didn't I gotta do everything
around here
yeah ladies you can feed people that's
bananas
you got great a vitamin D organic milk
on tap we got a cup of coffee right here
bowl of cereal
I got you're a [ __ ] dairy I know a
girl she's lactose intolerant still
producing milk she's making something
she can't even tolerate
much like my mom did with me ladies you
live longer than man and you have a
higher threshold for pain than men on
paper you're like a superhero on paper
but that's the thing you ladies are so
incredibly such amazing beings yet
you're some of the most insecure people
have ever met it's always my looks do I
look good in this turn you on you like
that look fat and this is doing forever
about this uh okay you're a woman own it
I won't be the cockiest [ __ ] on the
planet what do you have a paper cut I've
been bleeding for three days this
[ __ ] guy huh what else you got all
you cut yourself shaving
Oh last week an immigrant waxed my taint
let's say you push out a kidney stone oh
I pushed that a little league player how
do you like that now give me those fruit
loops
but one of the most amazing things about
women the thing you get no credit for
ladies the most unbelievable impressive
thing is your ability to hide everything
everything is a goddamn secret you're
all in the CIA you have the real you but
any of you you let us see we'll go with
menstruation pretty big deal let's start
there you hide a pretty goddamn
well-mannered clueless we have to guess
that time of the month what do you think
time of the month is she acting weird
you anything down on your eyes our men
got there appeared to be blood
everywhere on the walls the sidewalk
everywhere everywhere this guy's walking
to work out [ __ ] uterine lining Jesus
Christ oh damn it
you made one of those masculine napkins
thank you yeah
oh yeah you too huh Jeff guess we're
synched up yeah
here we go yeah says don't flush it but
[ __ ] it it's all hidden hey everything's
hidden I used to work an office in
midtown Manhattan I was the only guy on
the floors meeting like a hundred women
I never heard one fart not a toot not a
queef nothing nothing
sometimes on Friday and bringing chili
and just wait nothing I farted up here
eight times tonight I walked it on one
win once once taking a [ __ ] it was like
I walked in on a murder scene she was
like get the fire fresh take it easy
you're allowed to [ __ ] on the OP see
we're gonna be [ __ ] I'm like hey what
you bring nothing you're given us ducted
ladies all your sexual stuff that's all
under wraps very hush-hush man Walker
I'm an ass man I'm a boob man you never
see a woman go I'm a ball gal yeah
I love that sack nothing
giving us nothing then you want to sell
how you're feeling and stuff what are
you kidding we're in the dark sometimes
I'll read a Cosmo a woman's magazine
just get some inside dirt one times
reading a Cosmo there's a full page
aren't alone how to go down on a woman
properly it's like this should being
like guns and ammo or feeling scream
Sports Illustrated teaches late we want
to please god damn you got fake
eyelashes hair extensions Spanx
foundation you should know what I'm
thinking have you know if I could look
like that's why it's weird what a
woman's like you want to have sex of a
guy get to know me first get to know yet
you're wearing three pounds of jewelry
clown makeup and a hole afar for four
weeks I know who the hell you are
that's why it's so important to have sex
if that's because we're horny psycho
animals we are but it's important as you
finally see behind the curtain for the
first time and its glorious ladies your
hair is messed up you're naked yelling
out filthy obscenities like damn who's
this your friend calls hey it took a
month but you bang Sarah how was it
great I finally met her you say oh man
all right well come over we'll talk
about them I can't she won't let me
leave
thanks a lot I'm Kevin Hart
[Applause]
so much I appreciate it praise Allah you
know say I'm gay thank you have a good
night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]